just before we get started with today's
video I want to thank brilliant for
sponsoring it to support bar graphics
and learn more about brilliant go to
brilliant org slash bar graphics and
sign up for free of the early
philosophers who followed in the
footsteps of Socrates no one was as
striking or as eccentric as Diogenes he
was the original stoic a man who rid
himself of the trappings of society
living in an oversized wine casket and
championing the lifestyle of dogs of
humans he also challenged all of the
norms of society shocking people with
his outrageous actions and his cutting
wit in today's by graphics we take a
closer look at the bizarre life of
Diogenes the cynic the life of Diogenes
is woven in legend and myth getting to
the facts of his life is difficult and
there is much that is not known we do
know that he was born in the Greek city
of cinn opie between 4 12 and 403 BCE he
was the son of a prominent civil
servants by the name of his sisyas he
was the master of the town's mint this
position would have provided the family
with a higher standard of living than
most people and this this is what we
really know about Diogenes his early
years ancient biographers tell us that
his fascination with philosophy it began
with a scandal involving his home city
Salemme was a busy Seaport situated in
the southern coast of the Black Sea it
was a crossroads between Crimea to the
north and upper Mesopotamia to the south
many of the people who lived in Sahay
had been resettled from Athens as a
result the city was a regional center of
Greek culture the coinage of Shinobi was
the preferred currency for regional
trade at some point an accusation was
made that the master of the mentor
sisyas had been tampering with the
coinage one accounts that of you bulla
DS claims that it was actually Diogenes
himself who was working at the mints and
it was he who damaged the coinage either
way both father and son they were forced
to flee the city
one account tells us that they were
eventually caught convicted and sent to
prison with high sisyas dying in his
cell while Diogenes managed to escape
[Music]
Diogenes now found himself driven from
his home town he had lost his home his
possessions his livelihood and this
citizenship sub-accounts claimed that he
traveled to delphine near Mount
Parnassus in Upper central Greece it was
there that the seat of Pythia was
located this was the home of the Oracle
the priestess of the sanctuary dedicated
to Apollo the Oracle was renowned as
being a source of wisdom and prophecy
Don Genesis is said to have consulted
the Oracle to inquire on how to restore
his besmirched reputation she replied
defaced the currency dodging EES
apparently took the advice figuratively
rather than literally having been
wrongly accused of defacing the physical
currency of his home city he would now
to face the currency of society he would
do this by finding a way to take account
of it moral values out of society a
biography written by Diogenes of latias
no relation stated he really too faced
the currency giving to matters of
convention nothing of the weight that he
granted to matters that accord with
nature and asserting that the manner of
life he lived was the same as that of
Heracles when he preferred freedom to
everything Dondre knees necks traveled
to Athens in such a further
Enlightenment's he resolved to take his
adverse situation and convert it into a
virtue he began to assert his pride in
being without a state a home or any
material possessions he referred to
himself as a cosmopolitan or a citizen
of the world he spent time in Athens
where he sought guidance from a famous
orator by the name of gorgeous at this
time there was a growing number of
followers of Socrates in Athens dodging
ease came into contact with some of his
followers he chose to become a disciple
of anticipation of the most committed of
Socrates as students to living a life of
radical freedom according to anticipate
was expressed in actions not in thoughts
or discourse he saw little value in
teaching much preferring to converse
with himself
Diogenes became like a shadow to rant
history's after some time that master
became annoyed at his constant close
proximity he lifted his staff in order
to warn Diogenes off and at this
dajin he said strike for you will find
no word hard enough to keep me away from
you so long as I think if something
to say dodge knees copied antis than
eases style and manner he developed
similar cutting humor and extreme
practices on one occasion Diogenes was
trying to sleep in a corner of a room
when he was disturbed by Athenians who
were involved in revelries and partying
1st century Greek writer Plutarch
related that he fell into some very
disturbing and disheartening reflections
he mentally compared to the efforts he
was making to live a simple life with
the licensure slimming of the people of
the city to talk goes on a moment later
however a mouse
it is said crabs harp and busied itself
with the crumbs of his bread whereupon
he once more recovered his spirits and
said to himself as though rebuking
himself for cowardice what are you
saying Diogenes your leavings make a
feast for this creature but as for you a
man of birth and breeding just because
you cannot be getting drunk over there
reclining on soft and flowery couches do
you belong and lament your lot but our
journeys concluded that if a mouse could
be satisfied with a few crumbs why
couldn't he be happy with little means
this incident it prompted Diogenes to
take his ascetic way of life to a new
level
he remained single by choice and
traveled very lightly with just a
knapsack and a folded cloak that he used
as a bet he had no home traveling from
city to city he would often sleep
outdoors but when he was in Corinth he
was said to have made a home out of a
clay wine jar that was as big as a
bathtub he would test his mental
fortitude by rolling in sand and summer
and hugging statues covered in snow for
extended periods of time during winter
dodging means he was constantly seeking
ways to make his life even more simple
at one point he saw a young boy drinking
water from his hands he then took his
cup from his knapsack and broke it
exclaiming fall that I am that who have
been carrying superfluous baggage all
this time he made no attempts to groom
himself in fact his appearance was so
unkempt so that people often referred to
him as the dog when asked why people
refer to him that way he said I fawn on
those who give me anything I yell bow to
those who refuse and I set my teeth in
Rascals
there are many accounts that refer to
the doglike behavior of Diogenes he
personally praised the nature of dogs
and so probably felt that the references
to him being doglike which were intended
as insults were actually
compliments he counseled others to look
to the dog as a model of how to live a
natural and unaffected life dogs he
pointed out perform their natural bodily
functions in public they eat anything
offered to them and they sleep anywhere
they also live off instinct have no
anxieties about the future and not
weighed down by materialism or
philosophy
it is unknown how many written works
were produced by Diogenes they range
from none at all
to 13 none of them have survived so we
have to rely on what others recorded
about his writings according to first
century right Phil Adonis Diogenes wrote
some very controversial things these
included that there is nothing in
existence that is naturally good he also
apparently gave defenses for such things
as cannibalism incest sexual promiscuity
and murder Phil Adamas claims that the
contents of Diogenes his body of work
were so scandalous that later Stoics
deliberately suppressed them in order to
clean up his image dodging is different
from philosophers like Socrates and
Plato in that he did not seek out others
to engage in intellectual discussions
with nor did he attempt to start up a
philosophical school or pass on his
teachings to others in contrast to
Socrates and Plato he also showed
absolutely no interest in politics or
civil matters he was the ultimate loner
who much preferred his own company to
the company of other people the one
exception to his tendency to isolation
was when he would travel to the great
athletic contests of the time he joined
the crowds of the Olympian Isthmian and
Pythian games that these events II would
spend more time watching the crowds than
the athletes as he studied what brings
man pleasure and excitement his
appearance and his strange habits would
inevitably draw a crowd which he would
play up to with some outrageous comments
or outrageous act he would then tell
people that everyone who followed his
example would be relieved of folly
wickedness and intemperance doggedly
seem to revel in the flouting of
conventional societal norms he believed
that anything done in private should
also be done in public as a result he
would regularly masturbate and urinate
in public once at the Isthmian games he
was talking to a crowd of people about
the struggle to resist temptation when
he had finished speaking he squatted on
the grounds and proceeded to defecate
the disgusted crowds they turned away
calling him a crazy man on another
occasion people began throwing their
bones to him as if he was a dog in
response he began to urinate over the
bones at times he appeared to go out of
his way to insult people for no apparent
reason there is an instance recorded of
one of his admirers inviting him into a
mansion and asking him not to spit in
the house in response Diogenes projected
a mouthful of phlegm into the man's face
so in a moment we're gonna get
into our points of dungeon is his life
when he's captured by pirates but before
we get there let me tell you a little
bit about today's sponsor brilliance now
you've heard me talk about brilliant
before they're a learning platform that
focuses on active learning this is where
you're given a short bit of information
on the scientific concepts and then
you're asked to solve a problem based on
that information it's a really effective
way to learn a few months ago brilliant
launched something new called daily
problems these are five minutes a day
that you can use to exercise your brain
and learn something new thousands of
people doing these daily problems
they've already learned how to use
computer science to effectively bake
cheese biscuits they've also calculated
the area where a snowflake and there's a
whole lot more each problem provides you
the context and framework that you need
to tackle it that means you can learn
concepts by applying them that's that
active learning this sort of short daily
practice can lead you from curiosity to
mastery in far less time than you would
think so just go to brilliant org
forward slash by a graphics and finish
your day a little smarter the first 200
of you to do so will get 20% off the
annual subscription and you can view all
of those previous problems from the
archives and let's get into that time
the Diogenes had a run-in with some
pirates
during voyage to a Ghana dodging ease
was captured by pirates first century
writer Philo of Alexandria gives us an
account of how his stoicism shone
through during this ordeal when he was
taken prisoner and when they fed him
very sparingly and scarcely gave him
even necessary food he was not weighed
down by the circumstances which
surrounded him and did not fear the
inhumanity of the Masters into whose
power he had fallen but said that it was
a most absurd thing for pigs or sheep
when they are going to be sold to be
carefully provided with abundant food so
as to be rendered fat and fleshy but for
the most excellent of all animals man to
be reduced to a skeleton by bad food and
continual scarcity and so to be rendered
of less value than before and then when
he had obtained sufficient food and when
he was about to be sold with the rest of
the captives he sat down first and
breakfasted with great cheerfulness and
courage giving some of his breakfast to
his neighbors and seeing one of them not
merely sorrowful but in a state of
extreme despondency he said will you not
give up being miserable take what you
can get the pirates but Diogenes up for
sale as a slave auction when the
auctioneer asked him what he was good
for he replied ruling over men he then
went on to let loose with one of his
sarcastic discourses turning the auction
on its head
he was then purchased by a Corinthian by
the name of Xillia deez Zegna these gave
Diogenes the job of tutoring his two
sons dodging he spent the rest of his
life in Corinth he was released as a
slave after some time it has been
recorded that when Alexander the Great
passed through on his journey of
conquest over the Persian world he
sought out Diogenes Alexander expected
to be met with the usual adulation that
he was accustomed to having heaped upon
him he came across Diogenes lying in the
Sun Alexander approached him and told
him that he would like to grant any wish
the Diogenes desired this was intended
to be an act of respect towards Diogenes
while also reflecting Alexander's great
power in response however Diogenes
simply asked that Alexander move out of
the sunlight Alexander was initially
taken aback by what could have been
perceived as a lack of respect but as he
walked away from the philosopher he
commented that if he wasn't Alexander he
would wish to be Diogenes there are
accounts of further interaction between
the two men according to Arab tradition
Alexander ones visitor
Diogenes in Corinth and found him
sleeping Alexander
kicked waken him and then said get up I
have just conquered your city but this
Diogenes is said to have responded
conquering cities is not to be held
against kings but kicking is how donkeys
act on yet another occasion Alexander is
said to have sent a messenger to
Diogenes to invite him to see the king
the stoic refused the offering
instructing the messenger to say to
Alexander that's which prevents you from
coming to us is that which prevents us
from coming to you the messenger was
apprehensive and told Diogenes while he
expected the king to say which was so
what prevents me and what prevents you
to this Diogenes replied you are too
powerful to need me and I am too
self-sufficient to need you
Diogenes believed that the truest level
of freedom was to develop a perfect
mastery over oneself this self
sovereignty was what he sought to
achieve in every area of his life first
century stoic philosopher Epictetus
summed up Diogenes beliefs as follows in
all that pertains to yourself you must
change completely from your present
practices and must cease to blame God or
man you must utter Li wipe out desire
hands must turn your aversion toward the
things which lie within the province of
the moral purpose ann's these only you
must feel no anger no rage no Envy no
pity in addition to exercising an
extraordinary level of self control and
self sufficiency
Diogenes also displayed fearlessness in
his speech as seen by his interactions
with Alexander
Plato was a contemporary of Diogenes the
two men were polar opposites on the
philosophical spectrum Diogenes
considered Plato's lectures and writings
to be a complete waste of time
he made fun of Plato's dialectic
teaching and his methods by which his
students had to learn
key terms on one occasion Plato was
delivering a lecture in which he defined
man as an animal who was a biped and
featherless demographers note endogenous
walked into the lecture theatre holding
a chicken which had been plucked and
announced here is plato's man on another
occasion
Plato was lecturing about his theory of
forms he spoke of a table hood and
cupboard dodging he's been replied table
and cart I see at your table hood and
cupboard Plato I seen nowhere Plato
attempted to ridicule Diogenes a simple
life star once when he saw him washing
lettuces he said had he bed caught two
Dionysus the ruler of Syracuse you
wouldn't now be washing lettuces -
there's Nile journeys replied if you had
washed lettuces you wouldn't have paid
court - no an AI seus with his wit
Diogenes was here making an important
distinction he was the true uncorrupted
philosopher Plato had curried favor with
the rich and powerful and been corrupted
in the process he had become enamored
with his own Fame and intellects and in
the process had become a hypocrite to
the teachings of Socrates for his part
Plato viewed Diogenes as a version of
Socrates gone crazy
in fact Diogenes very much resembles a
character the plato created in his
dialogue about the stoic masters
gorgeous in this work the character kal
achlys states that all things should be
done according to nature regardless of
how shameful they might be Plato refers
that calculus as an immoralist whose
actions occurred not by dialectical
arguments which he considers to be
wasted effort but by a sense of shame
there is never any evidence though the
Diogenes his actions were ever stemmed
by a sense of shame however there are
recorded accounts where he used shame to
encourage others to consider their own
actions once when he saw a young man
acting effeminately he asked are you not
ashamed that your own intention about
yourself should be worse than nature's
for nature made you a man but you are
forcing yourself to play the woman yet
this admonition seems to stand in
contrast to his own lack of restraint
with regards to such things as
masturbating and defecating
publicans condoning incest and
cannibalism despite his repugnant acts
and ideas Diogenes became an object of
veneration in Corinth in Athens on one
occasion a boy accidentally broke off
part of Diogenes his clay tub the people
of the city they were enraged they had
the boy flogged and they purchased a new
tub for Diogenes unlike Socrates or
Plato he was never seen as a threat by
the people at the stage rather many
viewed him as a curiosity even a
harmless clown and they were proud to
have such an attraction in their midst
[Music]
there are conflicting accounts as to the
death of Diogenes yet they all agree
that he lived to a ripe old age of
around 90 years according to some
sources he held his breath until he
expired in another account he is said to
have died after eating a raw octopus a
twist on the Artemis story is that he
was bitten while trying to divide an
octopus among dogs in Corinth and Athens
statues were erected in his memory a
statue was also raised in his hometown
of cenote it's inscription it read even
bronze grows old with time but your fame
Diogenes not all of eternity shall take
away for you alone did point out to
mortals the lessons of self-sufficiency
and the path for the best and easiest
life so sure I hope you found that video
interesting if you did why not hit that
thumbs up button below why not subscribe
why not hit that notification bell all
of those good things help this channel
out and let you know when we've got new
videos out so that's a good thing also
if you want more from me there is a
video from the archives linked to on the
screen also if you want a lot more from
me I've got another channel it's called
top tens
it's got daily videos on that channel
you'll find a link to that below and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]
but